dans un train roulant vers l'est
alexandre donne un cours de secourisme
france 1 et 2 et 3 et 4 et les
participants sont tous des employés des
chemins de fer russes ukrainiens en
mission humanitaire
depuis le début de l'invasion nous
évacuons des civils vers l'ouest
aujourd'hui nous allons à pau croft pour
faire sortir les gens et leur donner à
manger à voir et une assistance médicale
s'ils en ont besoin
vous donnez aux
bénévoles et membres des ong amène des
déplacés de tout le dôme basse à la gare
de pau croft mais aujourd'hui les
bombardements barraient l'accès à
certaines zones
le train démarre avec 101 déplacer à
bord pierre moins que d'habitude
ce qu'on entendra l'esprit l'ont amené
autant de personnes que possible des
endroits qu'ils ont pu atteindre où il
traite à tous d'aller pas voce reste
comme presque tous ici ludmila et sa
mère ne voulait pas partir où tu te vois
moi comme ma mère est invalide et que
tout était organisé pour elle à la
maison c'était très compliqué
et puis qui veut partir d'ailleurs
personne ne veut laisser sa maison c'est
vraiment
génial lui a été blessé lors d'une
explosion à active car
j'étais en train de faire du vélo quand
un mortier est tombé tout près
ils feront ce n'est qu'un mois plus tard
quand sa maison a été touchée qu'il a
enfin accepté la proposition des
volontaires tapping pop je n'ai jamais
vu un minibus aller aussi vite c'est
parce qu'il y avait des tirs le long de
notre route et pas n'importe lesquels
des tirs d'artillerie
plus loin alexandre rencontre une
famille de sa ville natale pas tout
c'est devenu beaucoup plus intense les
combats de 2014 était des jeux d'enfants
comparé à ça
j'ai entendu dire que les russes
voulaient prendre l'ukraine en trois
jours et bien c'est complètement raté
nous allons gagner c'est la continuation
des guerres d'indépendance que nos
ancêtres ont mené et nous irons jusqu'au
bout nous sommes unis nous serons
victorieux
merci
les parents d'alexandre eux sont
toujours à battre mouthe aujourd'hui
l'une des principales cibles des russes
il n'a toujours pas réussi à les
convaincre d'évacuer